je ne sais quel rythmeadopter pour cette
rongen démodé on contacte de votre
épiderme je pencherai pa moderne j'ai
envie de vous voir lubrique c'est une
danse phénétique puis je vous sens tout
contre moi je froisse votre jupe de
soi
dansons
dansons allons
danser dans dans dans une quinguette
sor
dans les lumières
tamisées
camoufleront trop bien au
rides l'orchestre fouille reparti nous
sommes SEP fois réunis on tourne on
tourne est malade quelle belle
fonfarenade musiciens sont à nouveau
revenus sous le chapiteau ils repartent
encore de plus belle et tomemmené par
l'escarcelle dansons
dansons Royon de la
f
dans jusqu'à
l'épuisement
dansons je vois la mar que de vos
femes c'est donc ça l'arc-en-ciel du
temps je ne sais plus me dominer je suis
un robot remonté si nous mourrions sur
cette danse nous sommes tous deux entrés
en
[Musique]
transance dansons
dansons nos corps
s'affent dans
dansons c'est la dernière
ronde
dansons mais soudain sur le
se je
sens votre corps qui
s'ondre